hello this is matthew from simply learn
and today we're going to dig
through what docker is and how you could
be using it within your own devops
environment so let's get started
in this presentation we're going to go
through a number of key things we're
going to compare
docker versus traditional virtual
machines and what are the differences
and why you want to choose docker over a
virtual environment
we'll go through the advantages of
working with docker and the structure
and how you would build out a docker
environment
and during that structure we'll dig
through the components and the advanced
components within docker
at the end of the presentation we'll go
through some basic commands and then
show you how those basic commands can be
used in a live demo
so with all that said let's get started
so let's first of all compare docker
with a traditional virtual machine so
here we have the architecture on the
left and right of
a traditional virtual machine versus a
darker environment
and there are some things that you'll
probably see immediately that are
big differences one is that the virtual
environment has
hypervisor layer whereas the docker
environment has a docker engine layer
and then in addition to that there are
additional layers
within the virtual machine each of these
really start compounding and creating
very significant differences between
a docker environment and a virtual
machine environment so
with a virtual machine the actual memory
usage is very high whereas with the
docker environment the memory usage is
very low
if we look at performance virtual
machines when you start
building out particularly more than one
virtual machine on
a server the performance starts
degrading and starts getting
poorer whereas with docker the
performance always stays really good
this is largely due to the lightweight
architecture
used to construct the docker containers
themselves
if we look at portability virtual
machines just are terrible for
portability they're still dependent on
the host operating system
and there's just a lot of problems that
happen when you
are using virtual machines for
portability in contrast
docker was designed for portability so
you can actually build solutions in a
docker container environment and have
the guarantee that the
solution will work as you have built it
no matter where it's hosted
finally boot up time now the bit up time
for a virtual machine
is fairly slow in comparison to the boot
up time for a docker environment which
is
almost instantaneous so we look at these
in a little bit more detail
one of the other challenges that you
have with a virtual machine
is that if you have unused
memory within the environment you cannot
reallocate that memory so if you set up
an environment that has nine gigs of
memory that's being used we have
six gigs that are free you can't do
anything with it though that
whole nine gig has been allocated to
that virtual machine
in contrast with docker if you have nine
gigs and six gigs becomes free
that free memory can then be reallocated
and reused
across other containers used within that
docker environment
another challenge is running multiple
virtual machines
in a single environment that can lead to
instability and performance issues
whereas docker is designed to run
multiple containers in the same
environment and
actually gets better the more containers
you run in that hosted single docker
engine portability issues with a
virtual machine is the software can work
on one machine but then when you move
that vm to another machine
suddenly some of the software won't work
because there are some dependencies that
haven't been inherited correctly
whereas docker itself is designed
specifically
to be able to run across multiple
environments and
to be deployed very easily across the
systems
and again the actual boot up time for a
vm it just
takes a long time you took about minutes
in contrast to the
milliseconds that it takes for a docker
environment to boot up
so let's dig into what docker actually
is so
docker itself is an os virtualized
software
platform and it allows it organizations
to really
easily create deploy and run
applications as what
are called docker containers that have
all the dependencies within that
container
very easily and the container itself is
really just a very lightweight package
that has
all the instructions and dependencies
such as frameworks
libraries bins etc all within that
container
and that container itself can then be
moved from environment to environment
very easily if we to look in our dev ops
life cycle the place where docker really
shines is
in deployment because when you're
actually at the point of deploying your
solution
you want to be able to guarantee that
the code that has been tested will
actually work in the production
environment but in addition to that
what we often find is that when you're
actually building the code and you're
actually testing the code
having a container running the solution
at those stages is also
a really good plus because what happens
is that the people building the code and
testing the code
are able to validate their work in the
same environment that would be used for
the production environment so
really you can use docker in multiple
stages within your devops cycle
but it becomes really valuable in the
deployment stage
so let's look at some of the key
advantages that you have with docker
some things that we've already covered
is that you can do
rapid deployment and you can do it
really fast the environment itself is
highly
portable and was designed for that in
mind the efficiencies that you'll see
will allow you to run
multiple docker containers in a single
environment
as compared to more traditional vm
environments
the configuration itself can be scripted
through a language called yaml which
allows you to be able to
write out and describe the docker
environment that you want to create
this in turn allows you to be able to
scale your environment very very quickly
but with all of these advantages
probably the one that
is most critical to the type of work
that we're doing today
is security you have to ensure that the
environment you
are running is a highly secure but
highly
scalable environment and i'm very
pleased to say that docker takes
security very
seriously so you'll see it as one of the
key talents for the actual architecture
of the system that you're implementing
so let's look at how docker actually
works within
your environment so docker works there
is a what's called a docker engine the
docker engine is really comprised of
two key elements so you have a server
and a client and the communication via
the two
is via a rest api the server as you can
imagine
has the instructions that are
communicated out to the client and
instructs the client on what to do
the connection between the client and
the server
the communication is via a rest api
on older systems you can take advantage
of the docker toolbox which allows you
to
go ahead and control the docker engine
the docker machine
docker compose and kitematic so let's
now go into what the actual
route components though of docker are so
let's have a look at those key
components
there are four components that we're
going to go through we have the docker
clients and server we have docker images
we have the docker registry and the
docker container we're going to step
through each of these one by one
so let's look at the docker clients and
server first
so the docker client and server is a
command line
instructed solution where you would use
terminal on your mac or command line on
your pc
or linux system to be able to issue
commands from the docker daemon the
communication between the docker client
and the docker host and
is via a rest api so
you can do sim communication such as a
docker pool command
which would send an instruction to the
daemon which would then
form the interaction of pulling in the
correct components
such as an image or container registry
to the docker client
the docker demon itself is actually a
service which actually performs all
sorts of operating and performance
services and as you'd imagine the docker
daemon
is constantly listing across the rest
api
to see if it needs to perform any
specific requests
if you want to trigger and start the
whole process you what you want to do is
use the command dockered
within your docker daemon and that will
start all of your performances
and then you have a docker host which
actually runs the docker daemon
and registry itself so now let's look
into the actual structure of a docker
image
so a docker image itself is a template
which contains instructions
for the docker container and that
template is written with a language
called
yaml and yaml stands for yet another
markup language
it's very easy to learn the docker image
itself is built
within that yaml file and then hosted as
a
file in the docket registry the
image is really comprised of several key
layers and you start with your base
layer
which will typically have your base
image and this instance is your base
operating system such as ubuntu
and then you would then have layer of
dependencies above
that this would then comprise the
instructions in a read-only file that
would become your docker file
so let's let you go through and look at
what one of those in sets of
instructions would look like
so here we have four layers of
instructions we have a from
pull run and then command so what does
that actually
look like in our layers so to break this
down
the from creates a layer which is based
on ubuntu
and then what we're doing is we're
adding in files from the docker
repository onto that
base command that base layer and then
what we want to be able to do is then
say okay what are the wrong commands so
we can actually then build the container
within the environment and then we want
to be able to then have a command line
that actually
executes something within that container
and in this instance
the command is to run python so
one of things that we will see is that
as we set up multiple containers
each new container is a new layer with
new images
within the docker environment each
container
is completely separate from the other
containers
within your darker environment so you're
able to create your own
separate read write instructions within
each layer
what's interesting is that if you delete
a layer then the
layer above it will also get deleted so
what happens when you pull in a layer
but something has changed in the
decor image what's interesting then is
that the actual main
image of itself cannot be modified once
you've copied the image you can then
modify it locally but you can never
modify the actual base image itself
so here are some call outs for the
components within a docket image
so the base layer are in read-only
format the layers can be combined in a
union file system
to create a single image the union file
system saves memory space by avoiding
duplication of
files and this allows a file system to
appear as a writable but without
modifying the file which is known as a
copy on
write so to be able to get around this
structure within a docker
container the docker environment itself
uses what's known as a copy and write
strategy within the images
and the containers themselves and so
what this allows you to do is you can
actually copy the files
for better efficiency across your entire
container environment
the copy and write strategy does make
docker super efficient
and what you're able to do all the time
is keep reducing
the amount of disk space you're using
and the amount of performance that
you're taking from the server
and that's really again a key element
for docker is just this
constant ability to be able to keep
improving the efficiency within the
actual system itself
all right so let's go on to item number
three which is the docker registry
so the docker registry itself is the
place where you would host and
distribute
the different types of images that you
have created or you want to be used
within your environment
the actual repository itself is just a
collection of
docker images and those docker images
are built on instructions that you would
write with yaml
and are very easily stored and shared
and what you can actually do is you can
actually associate
specific name tags to the actual docker
images themselves so it's easy for
people to be able to find and share that
image within the docker registry itself
one of the things you actually see as we
go through the demos you actually see us
actually
using the the tag name and you'll see
how it is an alphanumeric
identifier and how we actually use it to
actually create
the actual container itself one of the
things you can do to as
start off how you would manage a
registry is you can actually use the
publicly accessible docker hub
registry which is available to anybody
but you can also create your own
registry
for your own use internally the actual
registry that you create
internally can have both public and
private images that you create and this
may be for various reasons of how you
structure your environment the actual
commands you
use to actually connect to the registry
are both push and pull
push is to actually push a new container
environment that you've created from
your local
manager node to the remote registry and
a pool allows you to pull
a new client that has been created and
is being shared so again
full command and it pulls and retrieves
a docket image from the
docker registry and makes it very easy
for people to share
different images consistently across
teams and a push command allows you to
take a new
command that you've created a new
container that you created
and push it to the registry whether it's
docker hub or whether it's your own
private registry
and allow it to be shared across your
teams some key did you know
in docker registry deleting a repository
is not a reversible
action so if you delete a repository
it's gone
so let's go into the final stage here
which is the actual docker container
itself
so the docker container itself um is an
executable package
of applications and its dependencies
bundled together so
gives all the instructions that you
would have for the
solution that you're looking to run it's
actually
really lightweight and again this is
because of the redundancy that's built
into how
you structure the container and the
container itself is then
inherently also extremely portable
what's really good about running a
container though is that it does
run completely in isolation so you're
able to
share it very easily from grouped group
and you
are guaranteed that even if you are
running a container
it's not going to be impacted by any
host
os peculiarities or unique
setups as you would have in a vm or a
non-containerized environment
the actual memory that you have on a
docker environment they can be shared
across multiple containers
which is really useful typically when
you have a vm you would have a defined
amount of memory for each vm
environment the challenge you start
running into though is that you can't
share that
memory whereas with docker you can
easily share the memory
for a single environment across multiple
containers
the actual container is built using
docket images
and the command to actually run those
images
is a run command so let's actually go
through a basic structure of
how you would run a docket image so you
go into terminal window and you would
write
a docker run redis and then it would run
a container called redis so we're going
to go in
and if you don't have the redis image
locally installed it will then pull it
from the registry
then the new docker container redis will
be then available within
your environment so you can actually
start using it so let's look at why
containers are so lightweight they're so
lightweight because they really have
been able to get away from some of the
additional layers that you have in
virtualization
within vms and the biggest one is the
hypervisor and the need to run on a host
operating system
those are two big big elements so if you
get rid of those then you're doing great
so let's look at some of the more
advanced concepts within
the docker environment and we're going
to look at two advanced components
one is docker compose and the second is
docker swamp
so let's look at docket compose docker
compose is really designed
for running multiple containers as a
single
service and it does this by running each
container in isolation but allowing the
containers to interact
with each other as was stated earlier on
you would actually
write the compose environment using yaml
as
the language in the files that you would
create so
where would you use something like
docker compose so
an example would be if you are running
an apache server with my sql database
and you need to create additional
containers to run additional services
without the need to start each one
separately and this is where you would
write
a set of files using docker compose to
be able to help balance out
that demand so let's now look at docker
swarm
so docker swarm is a service that allows
you to be able to
control multiple docker environments
within a single platform so what you
actually are looking at doing is within
your docker swamp is we're
treating each node as a docker daemon
and we're actually having an api that's
interacting with
each of those nodes there are two types
of node that you're going to be
getting comfortable working with one is
the manager node and the second
is the worker node and as you'd expect
the manager node
is the one sending out the instructions
to all
of the worker nodes but there is a
two-way communication that is happening
the communication allows for the imagine
node to be able to manage the
instructions
and then listen to and receive updates
from the working node so if anything
happens within this
environment the imagine node can react
and adjust
the architecture of the worker node so
it's always in sync it was
really great for large scaled
environments
so finally let's go through what are
some of the basic commands you would use
within docker
and once we've gone through all these
basic commands we'll actually show you a
demo of how you'd actually use them as
well
so if we're going to go in probably the
first command is to install
docker and so if you have yam installed
you just do yum install docker and
you'll install docker onto
your computer to start the docker daemon
as you want to do system ctl start
docker
the command to remove a docker image is
docker rmi
and then the image id itself and that's
not the image name that's the actual
alphanumeric id number that you want to
uh grab
the command line to download a new image
is docker
pull and then the name of the image
you'd want to pull and by default you're
going to be pulling from
the docker default registry that will
then
connect to your docker daemon and
download the images from that registry
client the command line to run an image
is docker run and then the image id
and then we have the if we wanted to
pull specifically
from docker hub then we would have a
docker pull and then the image name
and colon its tag to pull build an image
from a docker file you would do
docker build dash t and then the image
name and
colon tag to shut down the container you
do
docker stop container id the access for
running a container
is docker exec it container id
bash so we've gone through all the
different commands but let's actually
see how they would actually look and
we're going to go ahead
and do a demo so welcome to this demo
where we're going to go ahead
and put together all of the different
commands that we
have outlined in the presentation for
docker uh first is just to list all of
the docker images that we have so we do
sudo docker images and we enter in our
password
and this will now list out the images
that we've created already
and we have three images there
so let's go ahead and pull a docker
image so to do that we'll
we'll go ahead and type sudo docker
and actually we don't want to do image
we want to select
pull and then the name of the image that
we want to pull which is
going to be my sequel and by default
this is actually going to go ahead and
use the latest
my sequel command my sql image that we
have so it's now go ahead
and pull this image it's going to take a
few minutes depending on your internet
connection speed it's kind of a large
file that has to be downloaded so we'll
just wait for that to download
you can see the others have completed
just wait for this last file to download
almost there once that's done we're
going to go ahead and do is we'll
actually
run the docking container and create a
new container
using the image that we just downloaded
but we have to wait for this to download
first
all right so the image has been pulled
from docker hub
and let's go ahead and create the new
docker container so we're going to do
sudo docker
run dash d
dash p 0.0.0.0
colon 80 colon 80
and then we'll put in my sequel call on
latest so we have the latest version
and we have our new token and that shows
our new docker container has been
created
now let's go ahead and see if the
container is running
and we'll do sudo docker
ps to list all the
running containers and what we see is
that the container is not listed there
which means it's probably not running so
let's go ahead and list
out all of the images that we have
within docker so we can see whether it's
actually listed there so we'll do
ps dash a and yes there we are we can
see that we do have
our new container my sql latest
and it was created 36 seconds ago but
it's in the exit
mode so what we have to do is we have to
change that
status so it's actually running
so let's change that to running state
we'll do sudo
docker
run dash
i t dash dash
name and we can name it
sl sql
uh my sequel
slash spin slash flash
and that's now gonna be in the route and
we'll exit out of that and now
if we list out the docking containers we
should see it
is now an active container
sudo docker start
and then we'll start the scene and then
and we should now see it
there we are it's now in the running
state excellent
and we can see that it was updated six
seconds ago
we're gonna go ahead and we're gonna
clear the screen
okay now what we want to do is remove
the docker container
so we're going to do is check list of
images that we have
and to sudo docker images
here are the images that we have and we
have my sql is listed
and what we want to do is delete my sql
and to do that we're going to type in
sudo docker rm-f
image mysql
run that command and what we'll find is
the image there's no such image oh okay
so what we actually have to do is we
have to go and see
that the image is now gone it's been
removed
excellent it's exactly what we wanted to
see
and we can also delete an image by its
image id
as well
however if an image is running and
active we have to kill that image first
so we'll go ahead and we're going to
select
the image id we'll copy that
and it's going to replace that
it won't be able to actually run
correctly because
the image is active so what we have to
do now is
stop the image and then we can kill it
so it's in the running state so we have
to
do so we do
sudo darker kill and kill
sl and that will kill the container
and now we'll see that the container has
gone
and now we can delete the image and
that's going to be the image going with
image id
but easy peasy
okay let's go ahead on to the next
exercise which is to
well good so here we are we've listed
all of the uh
containers and they're all gone so let's
go into the next exercise final exercise
which is to actually
create a batch image and we're gonna do
a batch http
image so let's go ahead and write that
out so it's gonna be
docker run
dash did dash dash
name
white there's that's going to be the
name of
this http service dash p
8080 colon 80 dash v
open quotes dollar sign
pwd close quotes
colon slash usr
slash local slash
apache2 slash htdocs
slash httpd
semicolon 2.4
run that put in our password again
so what we see is the port is already
being used so let's go ahead and see
which ports
let's go see if we can change the port
or see what
ports are running so let's do sudo
images
and see which ports are being used
because
it's either the the port or the name um
hasn't been put in correctly so
sudo docker images ps
pseudo docker ps-a
and yep let's port 80 there
so we'll clear the screen
so we're going to change the container
name because i think we actually have
the wrong container name here
so let's go and change that and we'll
paste that in and
voila there we go now
working and we'll just double check to
make sure everything's working correctly
so to do that we'll go into our web
browser
and we'll type in as soon as firefox
opens up
type in localhost
colon 8080
which was the the port that we created
and there we are it's a list of all the
files which shows that the server
is up and running thank you so much for
staying with us today and learning about
how to use
docker in your devops environment if you
have any questions please post them
below and we will get back to you with
answers if you like this video hit the
subscribe button and then then
the bell to get notified of new videos
we have new videos on docker coming out
all the time and we have other videos on
other devops environments as well
coming out we would love to hear what
other videos you would like us to cover
put those in the comments below this is
matthew from simply learn hoping you
have a great devops day
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here